it's threatening marine life these deep
sea coral reefs are like a block of
towers we're removing the bricks from
the bottom of these ecosystems and
putting human livelihoods in Peril by
having more carbon dioxide in the water
it's slowly killing the ocean but it's
not climate change it's being dubbed
climate changes evil twin ocean
acidification the point at which we
could have avoided the worst of this car
crash I'm afraid is over
so how serious is this threat bubbling
below the surface it's a rush against
time to stop this and what can be done
to tackle it
[Music]
Vanessa O'Brien is an explorer who has
been to space
and the summit of Mount Everest
in 2020 she set out to become the first
woman to reach both the highest point on
Earth
and the deepest part of the ocean
I was going to the most extreme
environment on the planet in reuseful
submersible
the longer we're down the more likely
things go wrong
what motivates me personally to be part
of something bigger than myself to
contribute to wider knowledge more
inspiring than one person
after four hours Vanessa successfully
reached the very bottom of the Pacific
Ocean
an area called the Challenger Deep
nearly 11
000 meters below the surface
part of her mission was to collect
samples to allow scientists to do
further research into a problem many
people have never heard of but which
Vanessa had read about ocean
acidification
I chose to give my water samples to the
Natural History Museum because it was
their article on ocean simplification
that inspired me
in 2020 scientists at London's Natural
History Museum published a paper on the
rising acidification of the ocean since
the Industrial Revolution and the impact
of this on marine life
they studied shelled creatures collected
from the Pacific Ocean in 1875 by a ship
named HMS Challenger
then the scientists compared these
historical samples to Modern versions of
the same organisms collected nearly 150
years later in the same area
what we've seen is that some of these
organisms their shells have been up to
76 thinner in the modern day than they
were at the time of the Challenger so
our conclusion was that the thing of
these shelves over 150 years was an
example of one of the products of ocean
acidification
so what exactly is ocean acidification
and how worrying is it
the best place to start is Washington
state in the early 2000s
when oyster farmers were mysteriously
losing huge amounts of stock from their
hatcheries over three quarters of our
Oyster Bar we died it was a big big
impact for us and the impact is being
felt by the local economy that depends
on their business this High rate of
mortality at first was a mystery could
it be pollution could it be climate
change then scientists discovered the
cause
the changing chemistry of the ocean was
preventing baby oysters from making
shells
it was the first time ocean
acidification was identified as a threat
to marine life Washington state where I
live has the dubious distinction of
being Ground Zero for ocean
acidification ocean acidification has
literally changed the chemistry of our
oceans what's happening now is at a
scale and at a speed which is just
unprecedented and it means that we're
living in the first ocean acidification
experiment at this speed which is truly
terrifying
ocean acidification is alarming but it's
not exactly what it sounds like
acidity is measured by the pH scale in
the middle is neutral seven anything
lower is acidic anything higher is the
opposite alkaline
the ocean's pH level is around eight
meaning it's actually alkaline not
acidic since the Industrial Revolution
the ocean's pH level has decreased from
8.2 to around 8.05
this drop may sound small but it has a
vast reach it equates to an increase in
acidity of around 40 percent shown on
this map as a shift from Blue to Yellow
and by the end of this Century the ocean
is predicted to be a hundred and fifty
percent more acidic
Small Wonder scientists are concerned
I have two children I would love for
them to know about the oceans in their
science and geography lessons but if we
keep on going the way we're going with
oceanification climate change then my
fear is that they will end up having to
learn about these things in history
lessons
so what's driving this
there's a familiar culprit the carbon
dioxide created by burning fossil fuels
as the amount of CO2 in our atmosphere
increases the ocean's pH level decreases
this chemical change in the ocean makes
life much harder for many marine animals
carbon dioxide is such an important
player in many of the key processes that
just a small change in Ocean chemistry
can have huge implications for the
health of individual organisms and for
whole ecosystems
Dr Sebastian Henninger is a leading
Global expert on ocean acidification and
studies its impact on Coral across the
world
his research suggests ocean
acidification is the prime suspect in
the destruction of deep cold water Coral
which is essential to the Marine
ecosystem
one of the main reasons they're
important is that they support just a
huge amount of biodiversity and without
those there just would be less life in
those areas and less life which then
feeds up into the different food chains
as well
if the coral collapses homes for other
animals are lost and ecosystems
threatened
to really see how complex the framework
is here his forensic investigations
suggest ocean acidification is the cause
of a threatening condition called Coral
porosis
osteoporosis in humans is when we start
getting more holes in our bones we call
this Coral porosis because this is
porosis or dissolution of the coral
itself in California Coral porosis has
caused these corals to collapse and
crumble
the disease first attacks the dead coral
skeletons on which the living Coral is
anchored
these reefs are built up mostly dead
coral skeleton with a live Coral
continuously growing upwards a tower up
to tens of meters high so these deep sea
coral ecosystems are really cities of
the deep they're supporting all sorts of
other life if that dead part starts to
dissolve then that whole ecosystem
starts to collapse
Sebastian says studying California's
collapsed reefs could give clues about
the fate of deep sea coral in other
parts of the ocean we're very interested
in looking at the Californian Coral
systems because it is a window into our
future
another challenge for scientists is
understanding how the threat of ocean
acidification is combining with climate
change
if you can check the pH from these
samples today so now at his lab in
Scotland Sebastian is exposing deep sea
coral to more acidified warmer Waters
and decreased oxygen with results
expected in Autumn 2023 we can put these
Corals in these tanks and simulate
future ocean conditions and by doing
that we can see the time scales that
we'll see the collapses of ecosystems as
a whole
with marine ecosystems they're going to
come hotter they're going to become more
sour as we increase the CO2 and they're
going to become breathless as we
decrease the oxygen which is available
to marine life
this threat to marine ecosystems also
poses a threat to human livelihoods
across the world from scallop fishermen
in Peru to the indigenous people of
Alaska who rely on salmon
I've always been taught that when the
tide is out the table is set
Raven Cunningham is a sixth generation
commercial fisherman who has noticed a
worrying change we would go out and
harvest shellfish we would be able to go
get a five gallon bucket in a couple
hours
just the spring I went out for half the
day and only got a quarter of a bucket
Raven is an IAC chugak Alaska native the
IAC indigenous Community have been
living in southern Alaska for over 3 000
years
the sea has always been Central to their
way of life
but more recently both have been
severely threatened
devastating environmental and economic
effects of this spill going to be here
for many years
in 1989 the Exxon Valdez tanker spilled
over 41 million liters of crude oil
and the impact continues to be felt now
ocean acidification is another less
conspicuous but increasingly serious
threat to Raven and her community
my community is very dependent on the
ocean not only for economic benefits but
for subsistence everybody in our
community subsists in one way or another
the EAC depend on salmon especially
much like the rest of Alaska where
salmon accounts for more than a third of
its Seafood industry worth over five
billion dollars
it's now feared ocean acidification is
contributing to declines in both the
numbers and size of salmon our Copper
River King Salmon would come around 50
to 100 pounds now we're lucky if we
catch 30 to 50 pound salmon
ocean acidification could be one of the
causes of this decline because it is
killing the food source salmon rely on
these small creatures called pteropods
pteropods are the original poster child
of ocean acidification their tiny
planktonic snails that literally
everybody loves to eat
these protein-packed power bars are
known as the potato chips of the sea
found all over the world they're eaten
by everything from salmon to seabirds
so these tiny creatures can have a huge
impact not just on ocean life but on the
entire food chain we quite often call
them sea butterflies because they kind
of have this flying wing movement
they're very beautiful creatures looks
nice and healthy it's obviously very
active it's moving around but not we
can't keep the camera on it
but now the shells of this vital species
are dissolving in waters all over the
world
and with around 40 of the global
population relying on Seafood as a
significant source of protein there are
concerns about the impact on the world's
food supply chain
you can see all around the edges here
there's cracking and a great big hole
here therapods are now being found
around the oceans around different
locations around the world in different
states of this sort of dissolution and
these are indicators that oceanification
is happening out there in the real world
so what can be done to tackle ocean
acidification
well the most effective answer is one
you've probably heard many times before
reduce our carbon dioxide emissions
reduce reduce
we need to stop putting carbon dioxide
into the atmosphere reducing fossil fuel
consumption Remains the single most
important measure but there are other
things which can help deal with the
carbon dissolved in the ocean
growing plants like seagrass or kelp
under the water is one
they are very effective at absorbing
carbon
seagrass captures carbon 35 times faster
than tropical rainforests
but there are clear limitations
to really mitigate today's carbon
dioxide emissions you'd have to carpet a
fair portion of the world's oceans with
seaweed Farms
others such as this company in West
London are putting their faith in
technology we just came back from Hawaii
where we've built the world's first
ocean-sistered direct diet carbon
capture plant that's capturing on 37
tons of CO2 per year at a levelized cost
of 475 dollars per ton
capturing carbon dioxide from the air is
a well-established idea but hindal's
technology is novel capturing it from
the sea the company is targeting the
ocean because it contains more carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere we use the
ocean as our intermediary in order to
capture CO2 because the ocean has 150
times more CO2 in it by volume than the
atmosphere does
hindel has some fairly lofty Ambitions
remember the ocean's pH levels from the
1870s when the ship HMS Challenger
collected samples
hindel is hoping to bring those levels
back we are restoring the BH back to the
level that it was pre-industrial
Revolution we are going to restore life
back to our oceans and the company says
its system designed to sit inside a
standard container is scalable it will
need to be even once these containers
are finalized to capture just one year's
worth of global CO2 emissions at current
rates would take around 36 million units
from new technology to growing plants
underwater these proposed measures to
tackle ocean acidification are hampered
By An Inconvenient Truth reducing the
volume of carbon in the ocean will have
limited impact without reducing the
volume in the atmosphere
you can't get away from the fact that
like climate change ocean acidification
is the result of carbon emissions and
it's just one more reason to tackle what
many regard as the world's most pressing
problem the point at which we could have
avoided the worst of this car crash I'm
afraid is over we need to actually start
applying the brakes the big question is
how do we make this crash survivable one
that we can walk away from
look